have you heard of anjali
i have
okay see people keep telling me to look
her up and then many other people keep
saying don't bother she's way out there
which also makes me want to look her up
even further
and i think i've been on some polls and
you've been on some polls as
who should
she take with her as a representative or
as one of several representatives for
the planet earth well i never said i'd
go with her first of all so i don't know
why someone's using my name
you know in a poll without my permission
saying that you know they'll take me
anywhere you know i've no one's taking
me anywhere unless i want to go
somewhere
two um
you know the old saying extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence um
you know nothing would make me happier
if she can you know take somebody to a
magic cave underground and have
communication with a
with another life form um but
if that's the case and what are you
waiting for why don't i go now just
bring a camera crew go now you don't
need to make a big deal of this um just
go do it and prove it you know at this
we've seen this in the community so many
times before with people
making these bold claims and you know
man i really hope i'm wrong i'd love to
eat my hat you know i'll be the first
one there's an old saying we have you
know if if i'm wrong i will kiss her
butt in front of me she's window um i i
nothing would make me happier than that
uh than to to that to be true but
everything about how this is unfolding
doesn't seem doesn't seem legit to me um
it seems
showboat you know when you have someone
sitting on a chair with
well anyways i don't look i don't want
to be judgmental enough people are
judgmental about me i know how it feels
you know i want i want to give angelie a
fair shake but
but you better produce because if you
don't you got a lot of people riding on
this and all you're going to do is hurt
the cause you know with some outlandish
claim like this if you can't prove this
outlandish claim
all you are going to be responsible for
is being another one of those people
that are that are tin foil hat and the
reason why this topic was never taken
seriously so add yourself to the list if
you can't if you can't deliver
when i looked at her and i didn't look
at her much i just saw a couple videos i
didn't sense any dishonesty but i didn't
have a
i didn't have anything like a close
gander let's say
so you sense some grandstanding or
showboating
no no look i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
judge anybody i'm not i'm not i'm just
simply saying that you know if you've
got
extraordinary claims like that you've
got to deliver you've got a
responsibility now and and you better
not have an excuse not to deliver that